[موسيقى]
احتمالات واحدها هو
الخلافات
القائد او رجل الدين وهو قاعد فقط بالاسم
ولكنه تاب اللي حرس الثوري السيناريو
الاخر وهو
الاستيلاء المباشر على سلطان
[موسيقى]
كلها يعتمد على ديناميكيات المحليه
مواصفات
الطبقه الوسطى مثلا تنازلات في ما يخص
الحجاب
وربما حوريات اخرى في المجتمع بشكل
يستطيع ان يحقق لحارسه بين الطبقه الوسطى
ولكنه لحرس الثوري ان يمنح الحريات
السياسيه الطبقه ولهذا السبب فعل المدى
البعيد فان الانقسام بين الدوله سوف يستمر
الطبقه الوسطى هو التي طالب الحقوق
السياسيه اليوم ستطالب بالحقوق السياسيه
ايضا عندما
اداره البلاد عندما تحدث عن السياسات
الامن
الخارجيه فانا لا اتوقع اختلافا كبيرا
واعت تقريبا لا عديده من القرارات
الاستراتيجيه في ايران من دون نظام بهويه
وليس فقط جمهوريه الاسلاميه كلها ستستمر
واعتقد بان ايران بقياده الحرس الثوري
ستفعل كل ما في وسعها
[موسيقى]